mark zuckerberg recently announced that
metta is the new name for facebook inc
he stressed the metaverse puts people at
the center of technology and is more
than a mobile app
up until a few months ago metaverse was
not a word thrown around in everyday
conversation and now that word is
everywhere and guess which famous twins
identified that area first
[Music]
as we move more and more closer to the
metaverse you'll want art in your online
world
and i think that people already play a
lot of video games where they're buying
goods and services inside the games but
they can't really take them out of that
walled garden universe
the metaverse is basically an online the
recreation of the offline world in the
online
setting i think a good example of the
metaverse would be fortnite where kids
basically sign in or even adults really
uh people have signed in and they even
have held electronic music concerts i
think marshmallow hosted a concert in in
fortnite people signed in to go see him
play in this virtual world
not in an offline setting or a concert
venue um and so that's that's sort of
one example of a metaverse but it is a
closed world currently and we think in
the future those worlds open up
this is the third time zuckerberg has
followed them into a space they
identified first
i think that what we identify with is
this idea that you're crazy and and
nobody really you know it's the that
quote that people often attribute to
gandhi first they ignore you then they
laugh at you then they fight you then
you win and quite frankly we've been
crazy a lot uh in the past you know two
decades or so um and and so i think we
identify with that frontier-ism like
being really far out there where it's
sort of this secret hiding in plain
sight if you will
the idea of a metaverse is easier to
understand when you see these tangible
examples especially in video games but
the question is will people want to
exist in mark zuckerberg's metaverbs
[Music]
you